hey youtubers is Charlie so following up
on the big destro can ounce Minh you
know Deathstroke the Terminator coming
to the DC movies gonna face off against
Batman in the solo film and being
Justice League so there are a couple of
big actors that I feel could pull off
the role so let's just break it down if
you hadn't heard before then you've
heard it now Joe Manganiello is like the
current leading rumor for Deathstroke
for the Slade Wilson character he's part
of that pantheon of bankable a list
actors that you can put in roles like
that and will guarantee a certain number
of asses and seats but if you're gonna
be in a Batman movie or even a Justice
League movie that's not as big a concern
you just want like a really strong
character they could potentially go into
a solo franchise you know distro
technically not a villain in the grand
scheme of things you hear that term
honor amongst thieves he's one of the
few that actually lives by that code
like he has a very strong code of honor
but he's an assassin for hire so even if
you haven't read comics if you saw
Suicide Squad that was kind of in the
Deadshot character but the difference
between Deadshot and Deathstroke I think
we can all agree is that Deathstroke is
a big upgrade in terms of abilities
power levels in the types of weapons
that he uses Deadshot has dead aim he
can hit any target with his guns but
therein lies his weakness he's ultra
specific when it comes to weapons
Deathstroke is just an all-around
amazing assassin and he's freakin huge
he's like a walking tank Ben Affleck is
one of the tallest actors in the DC
movies right now he's even taller than
Henry Cavill normally you think that
Superman would be like the biggest guy
in the DC Universe technically if
they're standing next to each other
Batman is currently the biggest person
in the DC Universe I guess if you wanted
to get really technical about it you
would say The Killer Croc is supposed to
be the biggest but he's part monster
like he's severely mutated Deathstroke
is just a normal person that's huge Joe
Manganiello about the same height as Ben
Affleck and he even kind of looks like
you would expect Slade Wilson to look
silver streaks now Slade Wilson in the
comics has like completely white hair
but I don't think that's really
important for the character in the
movies as long as he embodies the tone
of the character it's good performance
and he mostly looks like the comic book
version of the character I think he's a
really safe pick but let me know in the
comments who would you guys like to see
play Deathstroke you know Joe
Manganiello is an awesome actor I feel
like Stephen Lang Tom Hardy would also
be good pics just let me know in the
comments who do you want to be Slade
Wilson in the DC movies but what I'm
expecting from him in Justice League
because it's gonna be something of it's
like a very small presence he's not
gonna be a much bigger character til
later movies so I think it's gonna be a
very boba fett type appearance where he
doesn't take the mask off maybe you see
him take someone down in a really badass
way like maybe some sort of end tag when
he kills a less desirable character you
know you don't to make the character too
unlikable so most of the people the
Deathstroke winds up killing are killers
themselves I think that was also part of
the Deadshot character in Suicide Squad
most of the people he was hired to kill
were also very bad people but if you're
starting to think about the Teen Titans
comics the way his children work into
eventual stories I don't know if they're
gonna go right there because they just
did Deadshot with his little girl and
they try not to replicate stories too
much so even though the idea of regret
remorse redemption are all very
important for the Deathstroke character
I think they're gonna have to work up to
that but you can see a situation where
by Amanda Waller would blackmail
Deathstroke into taking a contract by
holding one of his children or part of
his family or somebody he feels really
loyal to like Billy wintergreen they
even did that in the Deathstroke rebirth
comic where his mentor is being held by
rebels Billy wintergreen he has to call
an audible during a hit on clock King
like he's ordered to kill clock King has
to make a deal with him on the fly in
order to get the person that's very
close to him that's held captive we
later find out that it's Billy
wintergreen but make no mistake
Deathstroke is still a very terrible
very ruthless character it's just that
he has a very strong moral code it's
just the job of the movies to let you
know how that's different from Batman's
code and I think that's gonna be one of
the more difficult things to do like
getting that across like they want you
to root for Deathstroke but also
understand that he's an antagonist so
like you see a Batman movie Batman is
always gonna be the hero like you want
him to be whoever the bad guy is in the
movie so I feel like any fight between
Batman and Deathstroke in the movies is
gonna end in a draw situation we're
about you know Deathstroke is the much
better fighter but Batman will have some
sort of advantage that will allow him to
get the upper hand so that's always
where a lot of movies fall afoul like he
didn't have a really awesome fight with
Batman and dust rope but one of them had
to walk away the winner without the
other one walking away feeling any less
like the baddest I feel like that's
where people really get upset with
movies like this where like that man
beats Deathstroke and everyone's like
dis tropes like such a better fighter
like how did Batman possibly beat him so
I wouldn't get too hung up on the logic
really like thematically I feel like if
they can nail the tone of Deathstroke
they'll be fine and Justice Lee and
that'll give them time to do something
really badass with a character in the
Batman movie and you have to remember
that Geoff Johns is co-writing it with
Ben Affleck so you know it's gonna be a
badass story and here's a theory I feel
like if the Batman movie comes off
really well they'll let Geoff Johns solo
write the Green Lantern Corps movie
because Geoff Johns co-wrote Wonder
Woman he's co-writing the Batman movie
so the next big step would be for him to
write a DC movie just by himself in what
better movie for him to fix than the
Green Lantern Corps after the you know
the terrible Green Lantern 2011 film
they really need a big win for those
characters and I feel like that's what
Geoff Johns does like he takes
characters that nobody cares about or
haven't thought about a long time and
makes them cool again but who knows how
it's gonna go down and you have to
remember these kind of like the Kevin
Feige of DC now so I have a feeling that
even if he doesn't get to solo right a
movie by himself he will continue to
co-write some of the really big films so
you can walk away feeling safe about
that if you're gonna trust in anybody at
DC trust in Geoff Johns but if you guys
didn't know there's a new round of the
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video it's just a $20 Amazon gift
card so there's a whole bunch more
Marvel and DC coming this week so get
hype it's gonna be really awesome now
that we're within like the four week
premiere period for a flash arrow most
of the big comic book shows you're gonna
start seeing a whole lot more footage so
get hype it's gonna be a lot of fun
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here to watch that Deathstroke
teaser again and you can click here for
the Justice League trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody let's have
five I'll see you guys tonight